larissa Clark is a political economy
major with a minor in business
administration she has a 3.94 grade
point average and to present her career
plans are uncertain at Hillsdale she
attends the University Christian
Fellowship takes part in the soma
ministries and the United ministries and
belongs to the College Republicans the
Praxis political economy club and the
young Americans for freedom she also
works as both the student mentor and a
resident advisor in her dormitory she
previously took part in a full bridge
business program interned for the young
America's foundation in Washington DC
and joined in mission trips to the
Philippines and Nepal Larissa is one of
two children her sister Tiana is a
University graduate the family lives in
Huntington Indiana her father is a
professor and her mother is a video
editor for a media corporation thank you
it was the first semester of my freshman
year at Hillsdale and I was on a plane
wearing a gray Hillsdale sweatshirt and
struggling to fit my carry on into the
overhead compartment you know that
awkward moment when there's a whole line
of people behind you waiting to get to
their seats and you're the one holding
them up because your bag just won't fit
so there I was struggling in front of
everyone when all of a sudden I heard a
voice behind me say you're a Hillsdale
Ian you've got this I shoved my bag the
rest of the way in and spun around just
in time to see an older gentleman whom
I'd never met before give me a nod and
slip into his window seat now when this
occurrence happened I was just learning
what it meant to be a Hillsdale ian as
that kind gentleman referred to me as
but throughout my years here I have
gained a better understanding of what
exactly it means to be a Hillsdale Ian
and I want to share that with you I've
heard it said when people give you
advice they're really just talking to
themselves in the past
this rings true for me today one thing I
wish I would have known as a freshman is
that being a Hillsdale ian requires
humility and a lot of it we are here to
learn which means that we might have to
admit that we don't know everything that
we may be wrong at times and that's okay
there's a sign that you passed as you
drive into town it reads Hillsdale it's
the people i laughed the first time I
read it but it didn't take me long to
realize how true that sign is Hillsdale
really is all about the people dr.
Whalen once said the conversation of all
is a series of lectures to each what
does that mean it means we need to stop
trying to prove ourselves and instead
listen and learn because we are
surrounded by some of the greatest minds
in our nation so we can't let our
education stop at the doorway of the
classroom we must engage ourselves in
lunch discussions because that's where
some of our greatest learning occurs we
can't just try to justify our own
beliefs but instead we must humble
ourselves and be willing to hear other
people out willing to be wrong willing
to swallow our pride and shift our views
because being a Hillsdale ian means you
do whatever it takes to pursue truth
I've also learned that being a Hillsdale
ian means effort is everything I
remember being terrified my first few
weeks here that I was going to fail
every single class I was in but I've
learned that if you put the effort in
you'll get the results out yes this
school is rigorous but you're up for the
challenge you wouldn't have applied if
you weren't let alone have been accepted
Colossians 3 23 says whatever you do
work heartily as for the Lord not for
men
that verse has been an encouragement and
an anthem for me at Hillsdale I've
learned that not everyone catches on to
concepts at the same pace some of us
have to put in more hours than other
people in order to understand something
it takes me a lot longer to write a
paper I will get the job done but it can
seem like it takes me three times longer
than some of my friends but here's the
truth we all learn differently so don't
fall into the comparison trap don't get
caught up comparing yourself to others
don't obsess on your weaknesses but
invest in your strengths being a
Hillsdale Ian means you know that hard
work and a willing spirit can take you
anywhere regardless of where you're
starting from lastly I've learned that
being a Hillsdale Ian means you are
constantly challenging yourself I once
heard it said to be outstanding get
comfortable with being uncomfortable I
have a personal mantra that is along the
same lines I tell myself if it doesn't
scare you it's not big enough and I have
to tell myself this often obviously we
do not want to live our lives in the
confines of fear but at the same time a
little bit of fear is a healthy thing it
keeps you on your toes it pushes you to
do more and to be more I believe that if
you're not being stretched then you're
not growing go to office hours with that
Professor that you feel completely
intimidated by take one class each
semester that scares you s TS Eliot said
if you're not in over your head how do
you know how tall you are don't let your
fear paralyze you let it inspire you
because it means you're stretching
yourself you're growing you'll never be
ready if you keep waiting to be so when
it's negative 20 degrees out and you're
trekking to your 8am
you're a Hillsdale Ian you've got this
when it's 3am and you still haven't
finished your 15 page research paper due
the next day remember you're a Hillsdale
Ian you've got this parents when your
child hugs you today and says goodbye
look them in the eye and remind them you
are a Hillsdale Ian you've got this when
facing the impossible task the
incomprehensible thought the infeasible
situation always remember you're a
Hillsdale Ian you've got this today you
all become Hillsdale Ian's and you get
to devote the next four years to
studying how to live and love well to
consider the beautiful and pursue truth
what a gift and four years from now when
your time comes to take what you've
learned here and to go change the world
remember you're a Hillsdale Ian you've
got this
you